yeah my wife is my cousin or whatever
but it's not like what you think
whatever you know so one of the
characters in the book had really big
fake veneers so I had to learn how to
re-talk because I had such a horrible
lisp when I put them on so I had to
spend a month and a half wearing them
all day I had to get rid of the lisp and
work on the accent and everything and uh
no one from my life would speak to me on
the phone and so I would call Best Buy
all the time and talk to people at Best
Buy with my teeth on as as Donnie and I
would just start asking them about all
the different appliances and talk on the
phone I would talk about computers and
big screens and stuff I just would look
online and ask about each product and
ask a bunch of questions and I used to
call this one Best Buy in Honolulu
um in Hawaii of course and they were
super friendly and they stay on the
phone with me for like three hours I
hope someone from Best Buy watches the
film and it's like holy you know
like I've talked to that guy a lot on
the phone now they got nominated for an
Oscar to play Donnie I got to give a
shout out to all the Best Buy employees
yeah